[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is a very well caffeinated tim
ferriss welcome once again to the tim
ferriss show my guest today is cal
newport cal newport is an associate
professor of computer science at
georgetown university who previously
earned his phd from mit his scholarship
focuses on the theory of distributed
systems while his general audience
writing explores intersections of
culture and technology newport is the
author of seven books
that's a lot of books man including most
recently deep work digital minimalism
and a world without email i think some
of those allude to how he's able to get
so much done he's also a contributing
writer for the new yorker and the host
of the deep questions podcast you can
find him online at
calnewport.com and there are a number of
things conspicuously absent from this
bio and thank you so much cal for
sending me an elegant streamlined bio i
sometimes get five or six pages that
need to get cut down
dramatically so welcome to the show nice
to see you kel yeah well thanks for
having me
i thought
we would start
where so many good things start and that
is with steve martin
you have written about steve martin
before on your blog
you are prolific
on your blog which i very much
appreciate since that's where i started
as well in the blogosphere
what are some of your favorite lessons
or any lessons that come to mind for you
from steve martin and he's fresh on my
mind because
i had covid recently
and while i was recovering i was
watching comedians in cars getting
coffee and one of my favorite episodes
was with steve martin so let's start
there i'll pass the mic over
well martin was a big influence on me
early on in my career because of that
book he wrote because he wrote his
memoir
born standing up which was a
professional memoir the whole point of
the book the way he explained it in
interviews was i wanted to actually
capture how i got from nothing to being
a very well-known and influential
comedian i didn't want to skip the steps
he complained a lot of celebrity
biographies would sort of skip the
interesting part that one day they would
just be playing at the copa you say how
did they get there so he wrote this
professional biography it came up in
2007 2008 somewhere in there
i was a young grad student then i had
started grad school around 2004 2005. so
i was at mit i was blogging i was
writing books i was doing research
and that book was very influential to me
in part and maybe mainly due to
something he never actually said in the
book
but he said in a charlie rose interview
about the book
where charlie was asking him like well
what's your let's boil it down what's
your advice what's your advice for
aspiring entertainers and martin said i
always tell them the same thing and it's
never what they want to hear they always
want to hear here's my tips for finding
an agent here's my way from tips for
doing an end run around the typical
pipeline he says my advice instead is
always
be so good they can't ignore you
if you do that lots of other good things
will come that that was his advice that
hit me like a lightning bolt i mean i
remember at this time as a young scholar
second third year phd student published
some books i was thinking up all sorts
of schemes well how do i market my work
how do i have a new angle on research
that people haven't seen how do i maybe
if i write you know in a
cross-discipline way no one else is
doing and that hit me like a lightning
bolt it was basically saying actually
wait first just do really good work
and that's hard you're probably not that
good yet and you need to practice and
get a lot better that became the
foundation for
almost everything else that happened in
my professional life and so much of what
i wrote about so i i owe him i heard him
quite a bit for that inspiration
so let's use that as a
segue into focusing not just on what you
do but also perhaps
beginning to touch on what you don't do
because
just as with steve martin a lot of what
i find
fascinating or some of what i find
fascinating about you is what is absent
right it's kind of like
sort of like the the
the case of the dog that didn't bark in
sherlock holmes right really paying
attention to absence sometimes and
for those people who have heard a lot of
bios on this podcast social media
handles are not
prevalent in your bio among other things
we don't have to focus directly on that
but
let's perhaps start with
your definition of the deep life this
phrase this term could you just
unpack that for us and and tell us what
that means to you and what the
constituent parts are
the term the deep life is something that
emerged in the early pandemic though the
ideas and sentiment had been along
around for a long time in my writing
the pandemic hits and i make a lot of
changes suddenly i'm not seeing my
readers i'm not seeing my students much
more isolated and i began a podcast so i
could connect to people and i went on a
heroic one-month period where i wrote an
essay every day
and the whole direction what i was
writing about shifted pretty
dramatically i mean i was in the the at
that point i was finishing up a business
book a book about communication in the
business world and i've been writing
much more about the impact of tech on
business at that time i was sort of on a
roll with that
and suddenly i found myself in my
writing and
in major segments of the podcast like
talking about
life and building a life of resilience
and meaning and depth and that is where
this term the deep life came up my
audience just really was interested in
this and we in a symbiotic fashion
really began to work out
what we meant by it but at a high level
the deep life is a term for one of these
things we all know it when we see it we
just haven't really been approaching it
systematically it's when you see someone
living a life in such a way that it
resonates it feels authentic and
interesting and resilient
that they're not the type of person
who's going to look back at the end of
their life and say what did i do
we as humans have a deep craving for
that
but we often suppress that craving
because it's complicated and we don't
know what to do about it and we don't
have a lot of cultural support for this
idea of crafting a deeper life right now
that's not where the cultural pressures
are so we kind of avoid it and look for
the short-term
burst of good chemicals the short-term
burst of i feel good about this i gotta
like on this this beer makes me feel
good or whatever it is and we put it
aside and so i tried to excavate it i
think the disruption of the pandemic
cleared aside a lot of the noise
and i've been working on that as one of
the things i've been talking about quite
a bit is
systematically speaking let's put a like
a cal newport overly systematic nerd
computer science brain to this
can we break down what the deep life is
how you get there
what you need to do what you don't need
to do and it's really emerged as
something i've i've thought a lot about
all right we may we may take a bit of a
boomerang path to come back to that but
i think a lot of these topics will
intersect so i want to go back in time a
bit so we were just talking about
pandemic
let's go
much further back and part of the reason
i want to do that is these days say if
if someone comes up to me on the street
it's
nine times out of ten
about the podcast
and
let's call it in 2010 2012.
if someone emailed me it would have been
about tech investing in startups
but
my career at least
in any credible sense and didn't start
with that
and
really it was the four-hour workweek
that put me on
any map
to speak of
one of my employees
knows you and got to know you
through
study hacks and he moved from overseas
to canada to university he went from
skating through high school because
there really wasn't much required to
getting his first f's
and was
panic-stricken because he needed to
correct course
ended up finding study hacks your work
and
transformed himself into an a student
is that
where you first
found your groove would you say in terms
of public audience and
feeling some momentum in your career or
was it before or after that
right it's a good history to get into
that my initial books the first three
books i wrote
were aimed at students
there were there are books roughly
speaking of student advice though the
third one i'll touch on in a second
began to veer away from that and
actually that third book intersected
with with you in a way that you may not
remember but i i think i wrote an essay
for your blog back then about one of the
ideas
but i started with student books and my
blog in the early days was called study
hacks because it was advice for students
and the the backstory on that
is as a high school student
during the late 90s
i had started a dot-com company this was
the first dot-com boom no one really
understood this technology so there's
this brief period where we
thought that uh if you're young
that must mean that you really know
about tech in a way older people didn't
so it's like a brief moment of insanity
they would give 17 year olds tens of
thousands of dollars to do things we
didn't know how to do
but as an effect of that i was a 17 year
old who knew the business and
productivity section of barnes noble
very well so i was reading business
books and productivity books because i
was trying to figure out what the hell i
was doing
then i went to college
and i'm you know i'm taking on student
loans i want to do well i'm trying to
take my college career seriously and i
said great let me go
to barnes noble and get the books about
here's how the top students study so i
can
figure this out just the way i bought
you know a david allen book or stephen
covey book to figure out how to do
business stuff
and those books weren't really there
back then
there was a sense in the publishing
industry back in the 90s that you had to
be
quote unquote cool
or students would reject the book and uh
in that effort they accomplished the
opposite
so it's all these books with like kooky
people on the covers and it's all about
you know your crazy roommate and how to
deal with the dorm food and and i just
had this idea i was like look what we
need to do is write a book for college
students who want to know how to do well
exactly like a business book
this this doesn't exist don't try to
talk about naked roommates and dorm food
just be like here's how the top students
study like let's just do this don't talk
about the naked roommates that's more of
a show don't tell kind of situation i
would say so yeah you only need to see
that once
and so that's what got me started so i
had this idea and i was a writer in
college i was doing computer science and
i was also writing and you know as the
editor of the humor magazine i was a
columnist for the newspaper i was really
into actually humor writing but i could
write you know i'd train myself to write
in college and i was uh in new york and
hanging out with an entrepreneur friend
of mine and he's like well stop talking
about just write the damn book
so i was like okay we'll figure that out
and then i figured out how to you know
it's not that hard to figure out i i in
a sort of a tim ferrissian style i i i
found an agent and said look i i don't
want you to be my agent i want you to
just teach me how this whole industry
works i want you to teach me how can a
20 year old get a book deal there's a
very narrow path you would have to
navigate as a 20 year old to get a book
deal and she laid it out for me and it
has to be a book about students and you
have to know how to write and we figured
it all out and i literally let me pause
you for one second did she end up
becoming your official agent or not no i
was true to my word no she was a fiction
agent right now my memory was this was
actually
whose agent was it she was a she was an
agent who represented i think maybe anne
patchett it's like a very well respected
i might have that wrong that was my my
memory was like bel canto had come out
around this time so i want you to don't
lose track of this timeline but
how did you get her
attention why would she take this time
to sit with you so this was a family
connection my memory was my uncle's a
journalist and i said
would you be willing to connect me for a
and again this was very tim ferriss
style the way i went around this that's
why i think we're simpatico yeah your
book hadn't come out yet was very tim
faire style he said look uh one hour is
when i talk to him on the phone i do not
want them to be my age and i'm not going
to try to sell myself to them i just
feel that i need to understand
the landscape i'm not going to be able
to navigate this because it's too
atypical i'm too young i mean i'm going
to be ignored
i knew there would be a narrow path and
so that's true to my word and and so she
was a fiction agent so she wouldn't have
represented me anyways right that was my
memory so i was very clear and you know
what she gave me the roadmap she told me
like here is exactly
what what you would have to do like
among other things she said you have to
go do commissioned writing
so i went out and started selling
articles to these
middling
college focused websites and magazines
so i could i could have commissions the
second is that important just to show
that you're credible or that there is a
market for your writing yes
they're going to want writing samples
and they wanted they're going to want
writing samples on the type of writing i
was going to do and if i was going to be
writing a student advice book i needed
advice articles so i did that
the second thing she said any agent
would be worried about when i actually
went to find an agent was you know is
the content going to be good
and and so what i did there is i sold a
commission
for no money
200 or something for a nothing online
college magazine i don't even remember
what it was
i used that commission to do all of my
research for my first book
so i mean i i talked to because the
first book i talked to a bunch of rhodes
scholars in martial scholar like the
premise was
i'm going to talk to the best of the
best and extract advice from them and
this article required me probably to
talk to two people and i talked to 20.
you know i just person after person oh
it's for an article i'm writing this
article can i get an interview interview
for this article
and i had to figure out how to find them
but it turns out it's not hard you look
up press releases from colleges to learn
who had just been awarded a road
scholarship or a marshall scholarship or
a truman scholarship and then you could
often at this point email directories
were private but all you had to do was
find the email address of any student on
that campus and you said ah there's the
naming convention right you know at
harvard it's like
firstname.lastname.fas.harvard.edu so
then you could figure out how to get to
them and so i did
all of the interviews for the first book
and then wrote out the whole annotated
table of contents so i could come when i
started to talk to ages to actually be
my agent i could say
i can write look i'm an editor of a
magazine at college i write in the paper
here's articles i've written with
student advice
i have a good idea here is the whole
thing laid out and then the third thing
i did is i made the format of my first
book as easy as possible it was 50 short
rules each with a contrarian title each
two to three pages long so i made the
task as
tractable
as possible i was not going to try to do
some sort of sophisticated take and so
all of those pieces came together and
then the final piece was how do you find
the right agent
and what i did there is i used the
acknowledgement sections
of target books to see when the author
thanked their agent so i could see what
agent was working on what book and i
took the business book whose format i
was completely copying for my student
book
found the agent of that book wrote that
agent and said i want to do this book
but with student advice instead here's
all the stuff
and she signed me right before my 21st
birthday and i've been with her for 20
years now actually so that's how that
all started wow that's amazing so let's
see what year
roughly would that have been
when you assigned to that agent so this
was 2003 so in the spring of 2003 if my
memory serves uh i was 20 i turned 21
that june i was a junior in college i
signed a contract the book
i had pitched it as conquer college
and the head of the agency said you
can't have the hard k's right after each
other so we
we changed it to how to win at college
and i wrote it the fall of my senior
year of college i would just wake up
early and write for 60 to 90 minutes
every morning i just would wake up and
write for 60-90 minutes the format of
the book was perfect for it because you
could do a draft of one chapter in 60 to
90 minutes and that was that in that
book i finished that book while still at
college and it came out
right after i graduated i sold another
book while still in college so while
that was still in production
i upgraded like okay i'm now going to do
a book with normal chapters
and this was how to become a straight a
student this this ended up becoming
probably the the biggest of my student
books you know i had no idea how much
i'd been selling in the background
because it was never you know a big best
seller but it i checked
last week
and that little book has sold like 300
000 copies that's amazing with never
selling more than a very small amount in
any one week or month it just chugs
along so in that book what i did is i
said okay let's get past the more vague
stuff i just talked to 50 straight a
students it was hardcore like this is
how you take notes for a math class this
is how you should study for a an english
class this is how you prepare
for a blue book exam it was just nuts
here's how you manage your time this was
like one of the first books to
seriously tackle time management for
students and treat this as something you
should do
and so i wrote that almost immediately
and and i submitted that right after i
started grad school so so by my first
year of grad school i had one book come
out and another book in the can so i
just sort of knock those off real quick
i have many follow-up questions so a few
observations the first is you you're
mentioning that as a 17 or 18 year old
back in the dot com boom and then
subsequent bus you get tens of thousands
of dollars to try anything
i think we've learned our lesson because
now you have to be at least 20 to get
hundreds of millions of dollars
exactly what could go wrong a couple of
other things that just hopped to mind as
i'm listening to this because it is kind
of like deja vu all over again for me as
well there are a lot of similarities
and
one one does not tie in perfectly to
your story but when you
spoke to this first fiction agent
to ask for advice
if you had not
promised actually even if you had
promised not to pitch yourself
i do want to
mention that there's a saying or there
was at least when i was there in silicon
valley if you want money ask for advice
and if you want advice ask for money
and
that
very often the indirect path can
actually
reap dividends right in terms of asking
for for advice which this did it just
did it in a uh
in a more indirect fashion right it kind
of laid things out longitudinally and
then
the the other piece i wanted to to
mention where
that i think it strikes me as important
is that while you're in college you
created a book that was easy to read but
perhaps first and foremost you created a
book that you were capable of writing
does that make sense
and that is why for instance
in the four hour body or other books uh
tools of titans certainly
i have written books in a modular way
not just because it allows people to dip
in and out in this choose your own
adventure type of
approach but because it makes it easier
for me to write because ultimately if
the book doesn't get written it doesn't
matter how easy it is to read and
so that that also occurred to me right
if you had chosen to try to reverse the
order and write the
let's call them normal chapters instead
of the two to three page
chapters with principles maybe that
first book never would have been written
just given the time constraints right
and skill i don't think i could have
done it yet yeah absolutely so this
this leads me to ask and we're going to
bounce all over the place because that
is
how my brain functions or malfunctions
you graduate from college what is your
first six to 12 months look like out of
college
i mean the two things i did in college
is i wrote and i did computer science
right so i was like a real computer guy
i think we actually overlap when i was
in high school i went to high school
in a small town near princeton and so i
think this may be even overlapped when
you were there as an undergrad i ran out
of computer science to take and so i was
taking computer science at princeton in
the university classes when i was still
in high school
so i went to dartmouth college
and
was really just doing very well into
computer science so i was really uh like
a locked in sort of
computer science student and so i rolled
right out of dartmouth into mit and so i
was on a you went directly what type of
focus did you have within computer
science where were you most interested
in and focused on as an undergrad it's
just you're learning everything the
research i was doing as an undergrad was
more network system z and i made a big
leap when i
went to mit
i was mainly being interviewed you you
interview the way it works is uh
potential phd advisors you go and you
meet with them and then they they
essentially make you offers like okay
come i'm gonna make you an offer to come
join my group and so you go and meet
with them and it was mainly the systems
the systems oriented professors who were
meeting with me
but i had been a real big fan you know i
wrote of a richard feinman i'd read like
the james galeak biography genius i was
a fan of john von neumann of einstein i
had i had in my mind just this this
image of
mathematical research of standing at a
white board and proving a proof it just
was incredibly romantic for me even
though
math wasn't really considered my strong
suit and so there was one theory
professor who said
i need a systems person to come to my
group to help build wireless network
systems and i'd done wireless network
research so i went to her group and then
just pulled a fast one and just
immediately started trying to write
theory papers and became a theoretician
and so you know i haven't programmed a
computer since i arrived
since 2004 when i left school and went
to mit i joined a theory group at mit
and um have been a theoretician ever
since i i
haven't touched a computer since really
all right so if we if we look at
programming though and we look at
writing prose if we look at poetry
there are some similarities right and
depends on who you talk to of course but
i i think of for instance
an artist
named dimitri cherniak who works in
in
generative art predominantly at the
moment and
he put up a post recently on twitter
where he showed a screenshot of his code
and he said this is my art
so it occurs to me that you can strive
for and find elegance and beauty in all
of those different domains so there's
perhaps more overlap than one might
expect at least from a first principles
perspective
you mentioned
in passing i trained myself to write in
college
i want to hear more about that
because
i would imagine it wasn't this sloppy ad
hoc
approach just
given what i think i know of you
how did you train yourself to write
one of the things i always tell people
because it was my experience is that
in order to get the deliberate practice
aspect of skill acquisition applied to
writing like if you want to get better
at writing fast you have to be writing
for editing and you have to be writing
in the context of acceptance and
rejections because writing is one of
these things where everyone can do it
well enough that if you're mainly just
writing on your own so i'm writing in a
journal
i'm writing a blog i'm doing national
novel writing month it's just me you
know working on my novel you don't
necessarily get that stretch that's
going to improve your skills and so the
thing that mattered for me is that i was
writing for editing and for acceptance
and rejection so for editing meaning
writing for an editor you have a you
have a reader an editor who's going to
edit it and also we'll reject it if it's
not good and so this is actually why
writing for the the humor publication
was a big deal i mean you probably
remember from your time in ivy league
schools in particular there's a real
culture around humor writing because it
used to be
you know back in the days where
everything was the the sort of old old
boys network the vast majority of comedy
writers for shows like snl or or the
tonight show they were a lot they were
coming out of these ivy league
humor societies what is the name of the
humor magazine at dartmouth at dartmouth
it's the jack-o'-lantern the
jack-o-lantern and people may
have heard
the
term lampoon the lampoon is is that of
harvard and then you have a number of
different magazines at princeton and so
on yeah exactly and then they all have
these huge old histories you know so
like dr seuss
did cartoons for the dartmouth
jack-o'-lantern in the 1920s and you
know anyways so that's a very
competitive world you would pitch pieces
and if they were funny they would go so
they would back then it'd be you know
print magazines you would pitch pieces
and if they were funny enough they would
get in and if they weren't they wanted
it it was it was just starkly
competitive and then i wrote a humor
column for the paper but it's the same
thing to become a columnist they would
say no no no yeah we'll do that one no
yeah we'll do that one and if you got
five in the paper
you had the
possibility of doing the columns so i
think that really stretched my skill
and that helped that helped and and you
know i'll say the two things that help
my writing the most
to your original point here is a humor
writing turns out to be
incredibly useful
for any type of writing because humor
writing is all about the the timing the
pacing and the music of the words you
have to replicate the timing of a
stand-up comedian using grammar and word
choice and having to get the right
rhythm to set up the punch line way to
beat and nail it you have to do that all
with words
that gives you an incredible facility
with sentence crafting and so i mean
i'll tell you like today as a writer for
the new yorker which is very craft
focused you know they really care
writing craft is a really big deal over
at the new yorker the training i did as
a humor writer
is incredibly applicable because you
hear you hear the words as music and the
pausing in the rhythm it's you have to
actually the performance of the reading
you think a lot about it and that
actually really helps over there and
then mathematics just like programming
that has been the other key to my
success because if you do proofs for
example
it's you develop this sense where uh
it's not right this doesn't work the
pieces don't fit and then when the piece
is fit it's the the course of angels
right like your mind is like i don't
like when things don't quite fit and
when they do
it's dopamine coming out of your ears
it led to my style of writing which is
my advice right is very intricate you
know it's
lay out the generative theory that lays
out these pieces and these pieces all
fit together and you might not notice it
consciously when you read it but part of
the experience of my writing is that all
of the pieces i'm laying out there all
click together into a hole where
everything fits nicely and this is
symmetric with this and this makes sense
here and nothing is hanging out and it
reduces this cognitive drag that happens
sometimes when writing is a little bit
less the ideas are a little bit less
formed and it makes it harder to write
but i think that's been a bit of a
secret sauce in my work is that it's
it's cognitively pleasing because your
brain appreciates the fact that sort of
nerdishly and obsessively all the pieces
actually fit together
so a few things number one i think we
might have to call this podcast cal
newport a course of angels
that's
that may be where we go with this just
to get people in the door and
the second
is
what you're talking about in terms of
symmetry and structure if anybody
listening is interesting in exploring
that further there's a book called draft
number four
by
john mcphee who's a staff writer at the
new yorker and just a
behemoth of a craftsman and
really
really thinks about structure a lot and
lays out structure pieces graphically so
draft number four makes for a really fun
read if you are willing to go into the
weeds and be as a super nerd when it
comes to
that type of topic
i want to ask you about humor writing so
i was the
graphics editor so an illustrator and
graphics editor at the princeton tiger
which is
kind of the equivalent
of
the jack lantern
and
just a piece of trivia for people uh for
for whom this will make any sense
i took that job or i applied to that job
more accurately because
uh
jim lee had previously held that post
when he was a student and jim lee at the
time was one of my favorite
comic book pencilers or just beforehand
i've been one of my favorite comic book
pencilers has had rebooted the x-men
i think he's now at dc
still need to get him on the podcast and
i would sit at this desk
and at princeton there's this street
called nassau street with all these
gigantic mansions called
eating clubs of different names and they
all have their particular personalities
and you know f scott fitzgerald was at
ivy over here and jfk was also at ivy
and then this person was at such and
such so it has this storied and bizarre
history but when when he would go out i
don't think this is speaking out of
school it's pretty funny people go out i
want to say it was thursdays and
saturdays and just get hammered and i
didn't get hammered too much but
i opened up the drawer at one point of
this desk and i found drawings that
julia done
clearly when he had come back from being
completely hammered
at least that was my impression and i
was like oh my god these are treasures
and i don't know if i ever told anyone
about them because i didn't want them to
disappear they were like my little
secret
in this desk but the reason the reason i
brought this up is that
the
the head editor
of the magazine at the time ended up
shortly thereafter going and becoming
the editor-in-chief of maxim magazine
which at the time was a very very big
deal so it just kind of goes to show you
how quickly you can jump
my question for you
is
how one can practice humor writing or
cultivate an awareness of that timing
and so on that you're talking about if
they don't and most people won't have
access to
working at such a magazine
do you have any thoughts
yeah i mean again it has to be for
editing
right so you have to find a place to
submit with humor writing you need
someone who can reject you and help you
improve you need someone who could
reject you yeah and because it's like
the little things matter i would so one
of the things that the jack-o-lantern
did is we would also do sort of
onion style once or twice a year fake
newspaper so there's a daily newspaper
at dartmouth called the dartmouth and we
would print a paper that was exactly the
same format and we would just change
like the u to a v or something and we
would put it in the machines where
the regular newspaper was but it was all
onion style and i was good at onion
style stuff there's a certain like
dryness that has to work and for
whatever reason i have this memory i i
did a piece for it once and
so timing matters i don't i don't know
exactly a title but it was something
like
team from amish university places last
at robotics competition
[Music]
which you got to just there's a straight
laceness of it and i and i remember i
wrote this thing i wrote it as a maybe a
sophomore or something like this and it
was
just it had to be the exact rightness of
drawing and i remember the editor came
in
and added some extra things to it like
some quotes like oh and then jebediah
said like i had made it really dry where
i was trying to do it very repertorial
style and it like at some point you you
figure out they put like tinfoil on a
cat or something like it was something
but it was just it would be revealed
very dryly and i just remember he added
a few
like
quotes from some of the people and i
felt like the whole thing fell apart you
know i was like that's out of the
character you're breaking the drying it
like there's a hole or whatever but the
only way you're going to get that type
of fine-tuning is submit things have
been rejected have things be accepted
and then try to understand why
the thing they added is ripping up your
you're like this is just like this is
making me it's just not right i think
that really matters and then the other
thing for comedy writing is you have to
consume a lot of stand-up comedy i think
you got to see the timing
the timing of the top stand-up comedians
is actually the foundation on which all
human writing comes out of like at the
time when i was doing my column for the
paper
my column i tried to ape
dave berry style so i don't remember
dave berry oh i was just thinking of
dave berry yeah he won a pulitzer for
his his comedy column which is crazy
that's incredible yeah incredible yeah
but he was a timing guy dave berry is
great do you have any favorite books or
if people wanted to start with something
do you have any suggestions just read
his collections he has his collections
are fantastic
his whole thing was to set up and then
he would come in with the absurd punch
to the gut so he would he would set you
up and be kind of dry and the timing
would be just right beat and then
something completely absurd and then he
would just keep rolling so he'd be
writing about it would be mundane like
people bring too much stuff on the plane
to put into the overhead compartment but
i still remember in at some point in his
piece there's people with you know
full grand pianos and a uh you know such
and such brand john deere yard tractor
that they're trying to get up there it's
like the precision and the absurdity
that he just boom comes out of nowhere
and hits you with it that that has a
good
simon rich is really good at that style
i don't know simon rich he's a younger
guy
he was he was at snl i believe
he i think he's a lampoon so he came out
the lampoon he's at snl
and he does some shouts and murmurs for
the new yorker that's hilarious he's
sort of i think he's the modern you know
young version of dave berry it's a
little edgier than dave berry is yeah
but he he
the absurdity and and what he does
really well not to geek out too much on
on comedy writing but he does the let's
do it don't hold back the amplification
of absurdity so he'll set up an absurd
situation he'll take it very seriously
and he'll be very dry about it and it
just the absurdity of what's going on
increases and like the simon rich uh
his what he's really known for
is you end up in just like the most
absurd places but without ever losing
the dryness so he had this great piece
during covid about
like what should you do
if you're like an advice column like
what should i do if my kids afraid of
you know monsters in the closet and like
at first it starts off with kind of
reasonable advice and then it becomes
pretty clear that this this column
exists in a world in which there has
been a portal that has opened up and
like savage monsters are actually out
there in the world and are coming in and
taking and devouring children and like
by the end of the article it's all about
like you know i i your you have your
shotgun and you're explaining to your
kid that you're gonna die for the cause
as you leave you know the go fight the
monsters that have been whatever but he
keeps the dry all of that builds up
within
the idiom of uh q a advice column and
and it's great i love it and in the end
the great thing about simon unlike barry
is like it's actually a whole metaphor
for like the stress and anxiety parents
were feeling about covid and how like
we're trying to you know use the idioms
of normal news while everyone's
terrified and so there's there's there's
a heart to it that was really
sophisticated but yeah that's the dream
maybe i should have done that
well i'd say never say never i am going
to throw one more
hat in the ring and that is bill bryson
and for people who want a place to start
a walk in the woods
which is rediscovering america on the
appalachian trail it's just an
outstanding outstanding book also very
very good with timing
and
i want to
perhaps just return to and i think these
are related on some level
a term that that i have in front of me i
suppose i'm coming back to it visually i
haven't mentioned it yet but could you
speak to slow productivity and
you know perhaps you could could speak
to
john griffin's book the scientists you
mentioned a bunch of scientists earlier
in this conversation
because you you strike me also as kind
of a proof case
or a test case
of slow productivity in a world where it
is
thought by and large to not be possible
or to just be outdated so could you
just expand on that in any way that
makes sense to you well i mean i'll tell
you and this is literally true
what i was doing in the moments before
we logged on to this discussion right
now is it was in the other room in my
office this year with a notebook
working on slow productivity notes on
slow productivity because i'm thinking
about maybe writing a book on it but i'm
still in the earlier stages and and i
had gone for a walk earlier and had been
developing some new thoughts and i
wanted to get them down so i was
actually pretty frantically
taking notes in my notebook uh as i was
like looking at the clock like i got to
get into to talk to tim so when i say
it's fresh on my mind i mean it's
literally fresh in my mind and so
that's a big caveat that means this is
not a fully baked idea when it's i love
half baked ideas yeah so the ingredients
are swirling so here i'll pitch you what
i wrote down an hour ago
so as of an hour ago
this is the way because i what i do when
i'm thinking about ideas is i try to
basically
re re-pitch them out from scratch and i
do that again and again and and each
time i do it there's overlap with the
previous times but also new pieces and
that's how it polishes it's why it takes
me six months to a year to get for
example a book idea
ready to even propose like it's just
this is the like we talked about the
math mind like i need the pieces to make
sense
so my my current take on slow
productivity is
the problem itself so here's the problem
we're facing
the human brain is wired to it's it's
good at making a plan for executing
something that you think is important
and it makes you feel good when you
complete that plan
this is critical to humans why we're
different than a lot of animals we can
we can actually come up with a plan to
do something and feel motivation to do
it and feel good when we actually you
know we need to fix the fence we fix the
fence the cattle can't get out we feel
really good
the issue is
if you don't do anything let's say i'm
not making any plans i don't want to do
anything we know that makes you feel
terrible so you take away people's
autonomy their their sense of efficacy
and they're miserable we know that
but if you put too much on people's
plates so that now you have more on your
plate more obligations to which you have
some sort of ascent to complete then you
can easily conceive actually all getting
done
you short circuit that drive
just like your drive for hunger is
really important but if you eat like a
huge amount of junk food it short
circuits to drive and you end up
unhealthy so when we have way too much
on our plate more than we can easily
imagine how it's going to get done
it makes us really unhappy because we're
short-circuiting a cognitive drive here
and we get sort of anxious and
overwhelmed and it doesn't feel good
and so we can't treat humans like we
would a computer processor we're a
computer processor you want to pipeline
as many instructions as possible that
are sitting there so that not a single
cycle is wasted because you just want to
make sure that you always have something
to do but for the human brain
that huge pipeline of things that are
waiting to be done actually makes the
brain unhappy right
and so our
solution to this type of overload we
have too much on our plate in work and
in our life admin as well our solution
has been to
use fast productivity
so fast productivity are like tactics
and systems for increasing the amount of
things you finish on the scale of days
and weeks
so how do i get more stuff this is what
all productivity software is about lower
friction easier access to information
take out seven steps in the process of
getting this meeting scheduled we want
to maximize the number of things we can
execute on the scales of days and weeks
my emerging concept of slow productivity
says
shift that scale up to years months and
years
i want to maximize the amount of
meaningful stuff i get done in the next
five years
it completely changes the game in a way
that becomes very compatible with the
human brain
because now suddenly
well i'm going to try to do a lot less
the stuff i'm doing i'm doing it on a
larger time scale so maybe i'm working a
lot on it this week and then i go a
month without doing it at all and i have
a hard day today and an off day tomorrow
you have the seasonality up and down
rhythms which is a better fit for the
human brain
you get rid of the sense of overload
because if you want to produce you know
a good book in the next two years
that's a very different set of
initiatives than i want to do as many
writerly related promotional things as
possible this week like that ladder
could be a real source of stress and
overload the former can be a real source
of fulfillment and you you tend to
produce things of higher value because
when you're just focusing on
maximizing what you can do in the scale
of days or weeks
it diverts the sustained application of
energy and attention needed to actually
do the things that move the needle or
that you're proud of and so
i think it's a real issue
i think in the workplace we have to
completely rethink
work allocation our current mode of
doing this is completely incompatible
with slow productivity we basically just
throw an unlimited amount of work at
individuals and say it's up to you to
self-regulate it's like an impossible
task to ask and so you know i had this
new yorker piece recently called why do
we work too much and i sort of make this
argument in there that if we have to
self-regulate we're just going to end up
with 20 too much on our plate we're
going to let stress be the feedback
function that slows us down and in our
personal lives we probably
need to be doing significantly less but
the stuff we're doing do it better and
over longer time periods so
there's just this fundamental mismatch
with our brain that's happening right
now that this this epidemic of busyness
i think is causing issues
because of its mismatch with our brain
and maybe something like slow
productivity is the way out of it
so let's
let's look at some
some beacons of hope perhaps but we're
gonna we're gonna look at the ghosts of
christmas past first
so very briefly in
the scientists by john griffin you wrote
on your blog this was 2021 i think it
was uh towards the end of july that
you're that you're reading his
magisterial tome i'm not quoting uh
verbatim the scientist you're up to page
190 which is you're only up to isaac
newton and i'm just go now i'm going to
read verbatim even early on i become
intrigued by repeated observation though
the scientists profiled in gribben's
book are highly productive in quotation
marks by any intuitive definition of
this term the daily pace of their work
was incredibly slow by any modern
standards of professional effectiveness
and this comes then to i'm skipping
ahead
what you just said
when viewed at the fast scale of days
and weeks the famed scientists in
gribben's books seem spectacularly
unproductive years would pass during
which little progress was made on epic
theories even during periods of active
work it might take months for important
letters to induce reply or for news of
experiments to make it across a
fractured europe now i'm going to ask
you a follow-up question on that piece
i'm only going to read a little bit more
when we shift however to the slow scale
of years these same scientists suddenly
become immensely productive
and
last line i'll read no one remembers
newton's lazy lockdowns but his
principia achieved immortality
and
i'll ask a few questions and then feel
free to tackle them or answer a
different question however you like
so the first is
i would imagine some people hear this
say that's great but we just live in
different times like we are contending
with different problems
and a volume of stimulation that these
people could not even conceive of and
had there been tick tock and twitter and
so on perhaps newton never would have
achieved anything
which is maybe maybe not
and that's why i wanted to just note
that i want to ask about important
letters taking months to induce a reply
and so on they had some
some inbuilt friction in the system that
has been removed in certain ways
and you could perhaps reintroduce it but
the
question this leads me to which is
really the real question is
are there any people who come to mind
for you who are more contemporary
they could be dead but let's just say
within the last
20 years
who
stick out as being particularly good
at slow productivity could be a category
of person
but do we have it do you have any
contemporary examples
there's a couple places where we we
still see a lot of slow productivity so
one is
fiction writers and in particular
literary fiction writers but also some
genre fiction writers this is one of the
few places where you're allowed to
basically say leave me alone
i'll come back when i have a book
and so if we look for example at dave
eggers the novelist dave eggers
he works
in a he works in a house on a laptop
that doesn't have internet connectivity
so there's no wi-fi
and he just basically works nine to five
he's pretty hard to reach uh he talks to
a couple times a week from what i
understand he does have like assistance
to deal with some of the logistical
stuff but he just you can't really he
doesn't do much but work on on his books
another example is you know neil
stephenson i he wrote that great essay
you know years ago why i'm a bad
correspondent yeah it's so good so good
it's so good i mean it's inspiring but
basically his point was
he's mellowed out some by the way i
remember going to see him
do a book publicity tour uh back in
cambridge and and back then that was the
only time he would leave was to do
publicity tours and he seemed so upset
that he had to be there
he just wanted to be writing and he
really didn't want nerd he hated nerd
questions about like the canon of his
books but anyways but the bad
correspondent was like
if i answer all your messages and go to
all your conferences and answer all your
emails what will i have in the end i'll
have like a couple thousand messages i
sent to individuals if i instead
don't do that
and write a book that i'm really proud
of then maybe you know a million people
are going to read that book and so my
impact will be bigger if i ignore your
message so that i can be basically
writing something for a lot of people
john grisham is another example i went
down this rabbit hole recently
he
not long ago his longtime assistant
retired and he didn't hire anyone else
because he didn't need one he has
created this life from what i understand
he has created this life where basically
his editor knows how to get in touch
with him
outside of his two weeks of book
publicity you can't reach him he doesn't
do things i mean i know he does do some
things he does do some political
fundraising stuff but basically
he says i write my books once a year
and he said i didn't need to rehire my
assistant because not enough people knew
my phone number for it to make any sense
and you know so basically
he just set that up and and he put his
energy other places he uh he built a
bunch of baseball fields and became the
commissioner of the little league in the
one of the the town he lived so he put a
lot of time into that he's really into
coaching
so that was inspiring and then if you
look at
mathematicians and scientists like that
are really at the cutting edge
they're just getting after it you know
they're not on they're not on twitter
tweeting all day long for the most part
uh putting aside let's say like public
health stuff during covet but for the
most part the top mathematicians the top
theoretical computer scientists i know
the really leading edge lab scientists
they're doing their thing you know
they're they're going for their nobel
they're trying to get their fields
they're trying to
they're trying to do the work and so
that's another category i think
that you see where this is not for me so
i i take great inspiration from you a
novelist that really can just disappear
i collect stories by the way of
dual home professional writers who live
it's always just they live in a city in
the winter and then they have like a
farm they go to in the summer it's just
my dream
you know one day so yeah there's people
out there doing and there's people like
like me like you you hinted at it before
it's like the weirdest thing about me as
far as anyone is concerned is that i've
never had a social media account and it
turns out it's allowed
like today everyone understands it but
until like a minute ago people thought i
was literally insane
and it's fine i had friends who knew
what was going on in the world and sold
a couple books so you know it's like i i
think we tell ourselves that like we're
stuck in this
way of existence we're not really stuck
we have a lot of options
let me just add a few footnotes thank
you for that so neil stevenson for
people who don't know
first of all n-e-a-l
s-t-e-p-h
and
he'll pop up as soon as you type in
n-e-a-l but if you've heard the term
metaverse probably came from
his novel snow crash
has written many seven eaves my favorite
is probably cryptonomicon which i think
is a rare choice as a favorite but
personally well not in my world
computer scientists love kryptonomicon
oh it's so prescient in so many ways i
mean if you look at
you know cryptographic
sort of cryptography leading into
decentralized currencies and so on like
he is
he has spotted so many things around
corners
10 15 20 years in advance it is it is
really quite mind-boggling uh so neil
stephenson's a piece why i am a bad
correspondent i'll put it in the show
notes as well
i was going to include
why i'm a bad correspondent
in this book that i was working on a few
summers ago that i ended up canceling
which was the no book the the
placeholder title was the notebook and i
kept writing and writing and writing
this book on how to say no and coming up
with compelling reasons for why i should
not write the book myself
so it was kind of this recursive
situation where i end up saying no to
the notebook but the why why i'm a bad
correspondent is outstanding so i'll put
that in the show notes
you mentioned writers you mentioned
scientists
and
uh then one of the things that is
perhaps weird or that people consider
weird about you and that and that is
that you don't have social media
accounts so i'm going to ask you just to
let this
bake for a minute
what other things people would consider
unusual or strange right and you could
take that in any direction you want but
about you your workflow how you work how
you live anything
but before we get to that the no social
media so
found a gq piece
on you and digital minimalism
and
uh you mentioned that you had tech
company during the com
bubble
and
you've joked that
you originally didn't sign up for
facebook
because maybe there was i'll just read
the quote
there was probably a little bit of petty
jealousy newport says like oh why is
this company so popular i'm not going to
give him the satisfaction of using his
products so did you
commit is that just purely in jester did
you early on commit to that
and then it just worked for you so you
continued in other words was it like a
first principles decision or did it
start off in a different way
through the sands of time
i'm trying to remember because i had to
go back and do some research and i i did
confirm that facebook arrived at my
college in 2004 and i confirmed that was
true
and that was the first major there's
things before that there was friendster
et cetera but those were more niche like
there wasn't a real pressure to sign up
for those right my memory and again this
is through the santa time is that there
was two factors why i didn't sign up for
facebook one was just what you were
talking about so mark zuckerberg was a
contemporary of mine
he was a computer science student at
harvard at the time that i was a
computer science student at dartmouth we
had both started companies around the
same time his has been a little bit more
successful so i think
facebook ended up a little bit more
successful than princeton web solutions
which is what which is what i had been
running i mean you know comparable
if you just add seven zeros
so there was some of that because
like especially i remember like all the
women i knew and they were like oh this
is so fun i want to be on there like why
are they interested in this guy's
service there's some of that the other
thing and i think this is true because i
have a really strong memory of this
i have a weird it's not a phobia but um
an inability to do rank list right so if
you ask me hey what's your favorite book
which i get asked on podcast i don't
know how to answer it if you say what's
your two favorite movies i can't it's uh
there's there's probably a name for it
our rapid fire questions are going to be
great towards the end of this oh i think
you'll see you'll see all three i freeze
on these all the time or if i know
they're coming like i i've done as
recline show a few times i learned like
sorry sorry you're cutting out i'm sorry
what was that yeah your connection's
really bad they're all great it's like
enumeration and numeracy if i'm gonna
invent the word
and that was what early facebook was was
you would your profile was a favorite
quote favorite movies favorite books it
was a lot of irving goffman presentation
of self type sociology you had to decide
like what am i going to say my favorite
movie is my favorite quote to try to
create a presentation itself that was
and i can't do that like i can't so i
really remember it's the combination of
those two things i was like now this
isn't for me
and i got to tell you all it took was a
few years of separation
that suddenly i felt like margaret mead
among the polynesian islands because i
was the only person not using this and
it was so interesting like from a remove
it was like really interesting and i was
like okay i think i'm just gonna run
with this for a while and
i gotta tell you from the outside
it seemed more and more absurd not that
the services seemed absurd in isolation
the thing that seemed absurd my memory
was this presumption of universality
that these are technologies that
everyone has to use and it's weird if
you don't i thought they seemed kind of
niche like they're kind of cool and if
you're in the technology or web 2.0
maybe it's interesting i had nothing
against them but i was really wary about
this rising presumption that everyone
has to use it and i you know i'm an
internet nerd from the early days and
i'm like i don't know that we should
consolidate
the internet into two or three companies
where they built their own private
shadow version of the internet that they
control we already have the internet do
we have to use these private wild garden
versions of the internet and and this
idea that it was weird not to use it
that's really the thing that got to me
after that was the thing that really
probably made me an advocate
in the skeptical calm among social media
was not that i thought what was
happening on twitter was bad
um it was
why is it such a big deal that i don't
use it that's that's really what what
pushed me into a place of you know
something weird is going on in our
culture
thank god your personal everest is
putting together lists of favorite books
and movies if if you hadn't had that
problem who knows where you'd be
you'd be you could be just another troll
on reddit or something so that's a good
thing that you had that friction
let's
shift gears a little bit so i want to
continue to focus on the
unusual and unusual not in any sense of
impracticality but uncommon uncommon
things that you do or don't do
what is your roles and values document
do you still have a roles and values
document i do yeah yeah it's it's part
of what i pitch i pitched this
multi-scale approach to
planning things out and when i say pitch
i mean you know like on my podcast or my
articles
roles and values are at the top and this
comes right out of stephen covey
sharpening the style of seven habits
here are the different roles in my life
and here are the values that define how
i want to execute each of these roles
there's
professor
you know family parent right you know
whatever the writer whatever the rules
community member and here are my values
and and there they are and i look at
them and i refine them and you have to
think about it and then and then in my
scheme
you look at those when you then create
your plan for the the current quarter
because you want to
be in align with your your values when
you make that plan and then you look at
your quarterly plan when you create your
plan for the week because you want your
week what you do this week to be in line
with what your bigger vision is for the
quarter and then when you build your
plan for each day
figure out what to do with your time
that's influenced by your weekly plan
and there you have a thread that
connects everything you're doing
indirectly but without any breaks in the
links all the way back up to your values
so what i'm doing right now
is a multi-link connection all the way
back up to here's the things i care
about all right let's get into some
specifics more specifics here you've
written
very well
on and i'm going i'm going to get the
phrasing
imperfect but
you've written very well on how
many meetings are created or scheduled
because people otherwise don't have good
systems
for keeping track of things in other
words they're afraid of
forgetting to do something and therefore
they just drop a meeting in the calendar
with no clear agenda because at least it
functions to prevent the sand from
slipping through the fingers
you have this document the roles and
values document
if i were to create a role roles and
values documents say in google drive
i would be super excited i would focus
on it i might look at it the next day
but if i did not have some system
for
forcing me to
look at it evaluate it revise it it
would it would become lost very very
quickly i would forget i ever put it
together
so could you just walk us through
how you ensure that doesn't happen for
you personally with the roles and values
documents and then furthermore
with the quarterly plan and so on what
does your workflow or your flow look
like for those things well i'm a big
believer in what i call rooted
productivity right so there has to be
somewhere i call it the root document
that says
these are the
the core big picture systems that i
execute in my life
and
therefore
the only commitment i really have to
make is that i will
follow
this root document that this is the
commitment either i'm someone who
follows this root document or my life is
chaos and then that root document is
what lays out what i'm talking about
here lays out that multi-scale planning
that these are the types of planning i
do
there's a few other things that lays out
it lays out that i do david allen style
full capture i'm a big believer about
not having open loops
but i will do you so do you read that
every morning is this like your boot up
sequence
it's internalized now right it's written
down and my listeners do the same thing
like we put it in a directory you call
it root you know and and you put all
your planning documents in that
directory and you don't have to look at
it every day once you you internalize it
pretty quickly but just knowing it's
there
and you can assess yourself as am i
following that or am i not and it's a
binary and then everything else comes
out of it so we call it a root because
then the tree of all these different
systems and stuff grow out of it and
then you might be really nitpicking with
all these other small little systems but
they all eventually connect back to the
root
and to me that's a really big deal that
the biggest decision you make
if you're going to live a deep life
right because like productivity in
isolation i don't even know what that
means who cares but if you're going to
live a deep life like the ultimate
original commitment is
i'm going to commit to discipline in the
sense of
things i am going to do on a regular
basis because they matter even if i
don't feel like it
and like that is the biggest binary zero
to one flip that happens in in crafting
a life
what you commit to that evolves over
time you might find like this this is a
bad idea i've been trying to whatever
write down notes on a thing once a day
and that's not really working and it all
evolves over time but the zero to one
commitment is
do i have some sort of structure i'm
committing to with the goal of making my
life deeper or am i winging it that's
the zero to one bit that i think matters
more than any other
are there any particular
levers actions
anything that
have
helped facilitate that for you
personally sort of disproportionately so
right and and i'll just i'll share a few
things for myself which are
i think sometimes embarrassingly
primitive for me to even talk about
because i think
some of my readers and listeners just
imagine like i wake up every morning
with this like
mental karate chop and just like matrix
my way through the day with all these
sophisticated systems and that is
not really
how it plays out
and
i will say though that there are a few
things
one is looking at my
looking at my calendar on an annual
basis and trying to block out extended
periods of time for being offline and by
extended that's one two or three weeks
and ensuring that i have hopefully
something of at least a week once a
quarter so i'm actually leaving
tomorrow for
three weeks off the grid and
i will have no wi-fi and no phone for
three weeks and that's important to me
on a multitude of levels number one it
allows me to check in and see how
comfortable i am with myself when i am
not over-busied
it provides me with time to reflect
without the ability to indulge in the
temptation to go on twitter or check
something
so i don't i don't need to rely on
self-control in other words i'm sort of
saved from myself
it allows my system physiologically time
to kind of reboot and recover
and it also forces me to put
in place or revisit systems
that allow me to be gone for three weeks
so as an example
uh figuring out right now
and yesterday and today that my usual
checks and balances with team members
and assistants for wire approvals isn't
going to work while i'm gone so we need
to upgrade those systems so that we
don't have any issues because my
assistant unless there is a an emergency
that assists states a satellite phone is
not going to be able to reach me right
and then those systems outlive the time
off the grid that's an example of one
thing that i do that seems simple it is
simple
in theory at least
that has this huge spectrum
of ripple effects and there are some
other things that come to mind but i'd
love to know for you
if you're trying to focus on this deep
life
and rooted productivity
do any
which levers or actions have been
particularly
impactful for you that come to mind
i mean i think periodic reflection plays
a critical role for me too
as a professor there's a seasonality
that's built into my work which i wish
could be widely replicated so jealous
yeah i mean i suppose i could do it but
man it's such a great such a wonderful
thing
everyone who runs their own business
who's entrepreneurial where you have
some flexibility i think you should
integrate seasonality into what you do i
i have a big believer in seasonality in
all scales by the way busy and not busy
parts of your day busier and non-busier
days of the week busier and non-busier
months in the season i mean i think at
all scales we need it being
pegged all the time filling your time
all the time is not is not healthy for
us so for me there's the december break
and the summer break and just like you
so for my december break my last class
is on december 6th that's the last time
i'm on campus and for all the time after
that between then and when the semester
begins again each week i've already
blocked off one full day off from no
meetings no phone calls no podcast
recordings no nothing plus an additional
half day off for what i call adventure
work where typically i'll go to
trails outside somewhere scenic
sometimes i'll go to the museums in
downtown dc to just think about one
problem in a awe-inspiring or unusual
location i've already blocked those days
off because i want to get the most out
of december and then when i get to the
summer
you know it's it's with professors it's
a little bit weird we're not really paid
during the summer what you do at least
at a research university is you get
summer salary from research grants and
that's how you cover the the two months
in the summer
and at some point i after ten year when
i'd have to worry about that so much is
i decided i'm not gonna take research
grants for the summer i'm just gonna
take the summers off i'll fill in the
gaps in income you know with writing or
what have you and so i actually
literally
am not working for the university for
two two months out of the summer and
that's really critical for me that type
of seasonality is probably the
one of the biggest advertisements
for the professor life that i could give
what do you do on your days off
it's not clear like what on or off means
for me i i mean i i read a lot i think a
lot i take a lot of notes like for me a
day off what i care about is a day where
i don't have to be
interacting professionally with other
people like to me that's what off is i i
don't have to go on zoom i don't have to
go in for a meeting i'm not in front of
an audience it's i'm in full control of
my time
i don't actually like not doing things
when i have control of my time i love to
do things where i have complete autonomy
over my time i'm going to go for a walk
and think this through i'm going to go
work on a book proposal i'm going to
read this book i'm going to you know
then when my kids get home from school
we're going to go do something else and
so for me a day off is a day where i
have
full autonomy over what i do
the blank calendar day to me
is one of the more glorious sites if you
really want to hear the course of angels
forget solving a math proof or getting a
sentence to work right
seeing a day on the calendar where
there's nothing in gmail i think gmail
should have a feature where they just
sort of you know
pulsates an angelic glow if you see what
you see in the little little feedback
right there little feedback loop
i'm looking for some inspiration so
these half days
of adventure work at inspiring or cool
locations
i don't want you to dox yourself but
like
what are some
locations you've used or types of
locations and why did you choose them
right because even if you say museum if
you're in a city there are multiple
museums you could choose so how did you
choose a particular place and then when
you are working on
some larger problem or project
what does that actually look like is it
just pen and paper is it laptop where
you've knocked out the wi-fi if you
could give maybe one or two real world
examples that would be super helpful
i think a lot about location so if i'm
down at the mall in dc for example
there's a couple different
games i'll play
sometimes i'll go to the botanical
gardens which is it's a
the national botanical gardens it's a
giant greenhouse and and so it's just it
resets your whole context because you're
in a tropical climate with
palm trees and and there's these paths
that go through it and there's benches
and it's you're going to get really
sweaty it's very humid but i'll go there
sometimes i'll go to the national
gallery because there's a there's a
certain type of
connection to history
classical antiquity mindset you get if
you walk through and here's a leonardo
you know like you're looking at
especially like the italian renaissance
floor and then there's a an underground
cafeteria at the national gallery that
connects to east and the west wings in
which there's essentially no cell phone
reception so then you go down there and
you get coffee from the coffee place and
there's this waterfall and that you can
see through the glass
and then hiking there's a the toxic
national wildlife refuge is not far from
me it's uh you can go there and you can
hike there
there's the
rachel carson greenway that used to be
closer to my old house and and i would
hike the same thing every week and so i
got really good at the change of seasons
there's a real thorough move like
noticing
week by week how things were changing
and what was happening with the leaves
and i had names for all the places and i
would do the same hike again and again
and this is all pen and paper
it's me
notebook a uniball micro you know 0.5
millimeter roller pin
and
notes in a notebook oh a 0.5 guy i like
that fine point i'm torn between the 0.7
and the 0.5 well at the bleeding you
know i don't know deep inner conflict
i don't know man i think if you're using
the 0.7 you're going to start to get
some bleed i think i'm a masochist if
i'm doing cs work i'm doing math and so
there's a lot of little greek if you're
drawing an epsilon or you're doing
exponents or
you need a 0.5 my notepads are so full
of exponents and epsilons i don't even
know what to do with myself
so you have your 0.5 millimeter exponent
ready pen you have your pad
you go to the botanical gardens
you're drinking coffee
you're sweating your face off
what type of work are you doing like
what is it what does it look like for
that half day what
if we're looking over your shoulder what
is what's happening there
so either i'm trying to solve a
particular proof so if i'm doing my my
have my computer scientist hat on
i'm i'm trying to solve a proof i do a
lot of kind of graph theoretical stuff
and you're drawing graphs you're just
trying to make it work
or at least make aspects of it work or
figure out why it doesn't work and
drawing equations i'm drawing graphs or
if i have my writer hat on
i'm trying to crack structure
so for me writing of course has to
happen
with a computer and that's just it's a
whole other thing but i put a huge
amount of time in figuring out the the
structure of the ideas that i want to
write especially if i'm working on
something like a book proposal i
mentioned before it takes me six to 12
months
again and again you're going to find me
somewhere with a notebook just like i
was doing this morning right before i
got on the call with you here
just
writing trying to structure out index
outline that's not quite working you
know how does this fit together what
about this format for the book i'll
sometimes buy a dedicated notebook for a
book idea so it's a trick of mine i do
the same thing yeah but that's what i'm
writing yes it could be one of those two
things
what do you use for writing books what's
do you have a preferred software as
you're talking about indexing and
playing with table of contents and
structure
i have found scrivener just to be
a lifesaver in that department i'm sure
there are a million other options but
i've used scrivener for many many years
what do you use for your book writing
when i switched to contributor status at
the new yorker is when i switched to
scrivener i haven't tried it yet for a
book
so
we'll see about that
but i definitely for all of my articles
all my new yorker work all that
scrivener i love it why was that the
catalyst to switch to scrivener so that
type of writing so like new yorker
writing is very dense uh it's like dense
and information so
you're citing a huge number of different
you know you saw it in the article i
wrote about you there's like a huge
number of things you have to cite and so
the double pane feature scrivener's
absolute lifesaver like okay here is i
can just grab the article i'm citing and
it's on the right pane
and then i can quote from it directly on
the left pane or i can take a different
section of the article and put it on the
right pane so that the left pane i can
properly
reference it and then you just jump in
the composition mode when you're so you
know you're pulling in information and
kind of getting a draft of it and then
you shoot the composition mode full
screen best composition mode of any tool
out there and then your word polishing
and then you jump back ah it's a it's a
great tool i've loved it i've been a fan
for ever since i started using it i'll
uh just for people who don't have
contacts add a little bit more so
scrivener for me the reason
i i began using it is that
prior to that i'd use word and if you're
using word and you have
let's just say as in my books which are
both long and have many components if
you have
27 chapters
and you have 15 open
documents because you also have research
documents and reference documents
your computer will cease to function and
your brain will cease to function
but with
scrivener at least the way that i use it
you have these stripped-down
format minimal
documents that can all be looked at
within a single application
and you can format it in different ways
a lot of
screenwriters or playwrights use
scrivener i think that's initially how
it came onto my radar
i had not seen anyone use it for
non-fiction at that point but
i cut if you imagine your screen cut
right down the middle on the left hand
side you have this table of contents
it's the easiest way to think about it
and i will immediately break my book
into three or four sections even though
i may not even have labels for the
sections and then i decide
which
documents will go into
each of those sections and you can just
drag them around so you can play with
the order you can create another section
as an example and then you have research
at the bottom of that left hand pane on
the right side if you split that in half
horizontally what i'm working on this is
just how i do it what i'm working on
will be in the top right pane
and then below that the bottom right
pane i will have whatever research doc
i'm referring to since my stuff is also
very very factually dense and requires
citations and references and so on
and by doing that you don't have to
click back and forth between tabs or
between
programs between documents it's it's a
really
really elegant solution
and i and i hope you're not offended by
me focusing on some of the tactical
stuff but i'm curious in the thought
process
behind some of your decision making
right that's much more interesting than
just the output of the decision it's
like okay how did you arrive
at this so when i was reading about your
quarterly plan sample week plan et
cetera
in the end of this blog post and that
was from january of 2021 and and i don't
know if this is still the case
but
i'll just read this last paragraph to be
clear most of my obligations on my plate
exist as concrete items in my task lists
which as my podcast listeners know i
maintain using trello
but most of the projects that move the
needle in my career working on a
research paper writing a major article
never get
discretized i'm not even sure if i'm
pronouncing that correctly into
bite-sized actions on a list i instead
treat them with the level of intention
that their formidable difficulty
deserves
so
the trello use i've used trello i like
trello i tend to use
i've used both trello and asana
i'm curious
how you've ended up arriving at trello
trello has been my my tool of choice
recently for
organizing tasks and the way i actually
use it is
i do a different board for different
professional roles so i have a writer
board i have a board for cs research so
my role as a researcher and then a board
for the the teaching and administrative
pieces of being a professor so there are
three separate roles they have separate
boards uh the columns that i then divide
those boards into
represent different categories
you know i have a column for
i got to process this this is a david
allen idea where i need to put this down
somewhere this thing but i don't really
even know what this thing means i need
to do it's you know hey we need to
recruit someone like okay i don't know
what that means but i don't want to let
me just write that down under you know
to process like another hack i do is
anyone i meet with on a regular basis
they'll have their own column on the
particular board so if anything comes up
i need to ask them i actually just put
it on a card and put it under their
meeting column and then when i meet with
them i just go and boom boom we go
through it that's clever then typically
i'll have a column for like okay
definitely this week this needs to
happen so i when i go through my weekly
planning i'll move things to that and
and so i like that that different roles
different columns and i like that the
virtual cards and all these tools can
hold a lot of information so i'm a big
believer that all the relevant files all
the relevant notes if someone emailed me
something about this task that's
relevant you can just copy and paste
this all onto the virtual back or attach
it to the card and so it's it actually
is also an information management system
not just a task management system and so
that's been what i've been using and
then typically i really go through those
all at the beginning of the week but
when i build out my weekly plan i'm
often identifying off those boards this
is what i really want to get done this
week and and then i'm often executing
largely
off that weekly plan though i should let
me actually tim i'm going to give a
broader context here
because i'm kind of a weird guy i talk
about a lot of things so
i'm going to attempt to try to like put
all the weird things i do in some sort
of context
because we've covered a lot of territory
to unweird the weird yeah
just to like illustrate the weird
there's these two different main hats i
wear so there's there's a hat where i'm
a computer scientist and i publish
papers on
mainly like theory of distributed
systems
then there's a sort of
journalistic
public commentary critique type writing
this is like my articles for the new
yorker my new york times op-eds
my books mainly in my books especially
recently have really been about tech and
culture and their impact though they
have a
real practical aspect too
but then i often also talk about
productivity
largely because it's just people are
kind of interested in how i do these
other things so it's like become a it's
not necessarily like a tier one topic
that i write about though i kind of do
because deep work i think talks about
this for sure but then also we talk a
lot on my blog and in my newsletter on
my podcast about like what we're talking
about here because i don't think we talk
enough about this
in general so people are out there well
how do i organize my aspirations how do
i structure a life to be deeper and not
get lost in the noise but not be over
scheduled and so we geek out a lot on
productivity as well so just to give i
don't know if that's useful but a
landscape of you know i do these two big
things but then i have to care a lot
about productivity to do these big two
things so then i talk about
how do i do the productivity you know
what do i do to make sure that i can
still
write an academic paper and a new yorker
piece and a book and whatever like how
does that all fit into my life and
because i care a lot about it so i don't
that's useful but that's my uh
lay of the weird landscape for the
various things i do we are going to talk
about
say for instance a 30-day digital
minimalism experiment so i do want to
dig into that before we get to it though
we've got in 2019 the artist writer
jenny odell is that right yeah helped
kind of start the trend which we're
going to talk about when she published a
book titled how to do nothing
subtitle resisting the attention economy
so that becomes a new york times
bestseller
barack obama one of his favorite books
2019 then it was followed i guess a year
later the following spring by celeste
headley i'm not sure if i'm saying that
correctly but do nothing subtitle how to
break away from overworking overdoing
and under living then you have anne
helen peterson's can't even how
millennials be came the burnout
generation
maybe a little less inspiring sounding
it doesn't i'm always curious about
titling decisions
and the thought process behind it maybe
i mean it could be a fantastic book but
i haven't read any of these and then
devin price's laziness does not exist
now these these are
i wouldn't say entirely new in the sense
that you can go back to thoreau or
emerson and certainly you can go
thousands of years back
to like hakuin and you can find
discussions of overwork busyness
laziness versus contemplation
are there any books and i know i'm i'm
pushing on
your weakness here in terms of listing
so i'm not asking you to list but there
are there any books in the last
five or ten years
from broadly speaking this kind of
category that really stand out for you
it's an interesting category first of
all and like i sometimes call it like
the anti-productivity
category though that's not quite the
accurate label but it's a really
interesting category so you know my book
came out the same month as how to do
nothing so we were
me and jenny were paired and so many so
in the new yorker the new york times
book review the ringer there's all these
articles that came out where it was you
know always talking about us those two
books together so that was definitely
had a close experience
price's book is great i blurbed that
book celeste headley's book is great i
interviewed her for the new yorker in a
piece i did
i would say that what i would add more
recently a book just done really well
and i'll get into a reason why i think
it did was oliver berkman's new book
which is
maybe it's called uh four thousand hours
i might have the number wrong
oliver berkman yeah he's a british
writer and i blurbed that book because
it's great anyways it and the subtitle
is something like time management for
mortals or something like this
but it killed it the book did great it
came out a few months ago or maybe over
the summer i have a bad sense of time
but the
the number of hours i'm getting the
number wrong probably something with a
four 4 000 weeks time management for
mortals there we go weeks oliver berkman
with an
e-b-u-r-k-e-m-a-n yeah four thousand
weeks time management for mortals yeah
and he writes a column
for the guardian
so four thousand weeks is how many weeks
you have to live i think that really hit
and it really hit in particular because
it was introducing a
like a values
driven productivity you could think
about it like it's about all that really
matters when it comes to
organizing your time or being organized
is what you're trying to do is you only
have so much time and you want to
do things with it that's useful
meaningful and effective and to just
you know be busy for the sake of being
busy
isn't good i think all of those books
make that argument i think they're all
pushing back
on the like an empty crushing busyness i
am all the stuff i'm doing it's always
frenetic
but i'm
papering over the existential void i
don't want to stare down by doing all of
this when what i probably need to do is
stare into that void for a while
wait until the vertigo goes away and
then get up and actually start building
something real and i think they're all
touching on that because there's this
whole sort of fractured sense of
overload that's happening right now we
have all these different things coming
together
you have like the digital distraction
piece which obviously i'm sort of
associated with
is really a symptom of the bigger
problem so yes our phones can be a
palliative to this
existential despair
but the despair is there and the despair
is not going to be fixed by just getting
rid of the palliative and saying like
you know let's
not use instagram anymore it's still
going to be there we're using these
things all the time because we just it's
more palatable to be active and busy all
the time than sometimes to face what's
hard
about what's going on in our in our
lives or the world and i think all of
these books are picking up on that and
like we need to slow the hell down
figure out what we really want to do
do these things at a reasonable pace
slow productivity not fast
and
face the hard stuff and and make the
good stuff better all these books i
think are getting at that main thing
they all just have different angles out
there so each of them have a different
approach they take to this issue and
that's like its own interesting topic i
mean everyone comes at this from
different ways berkman comes at it from
like a humanist way
i kind of come at it from a humanist way
too in digital minimalism it's about
improving your life what does that mean
to let's say in oliver's case to come at
it from a humanist perspective what is
what does that mean like from a
perspective of sort of trying to
maximize or improve the flourishing of
the the sort of
unique and cherished being that is the
humans right like as a human
you are an important unique
entity to be cherished and should think
about crafting a life in which you
flourish right like that's the human so
it's kind of in this these lives of
indiscriminate busyness where i'm just
overwhelmed all the time and distracting
every moment is you're diminishing your
humanity so that there's like a humanist
approach where
and helen peterson might come at this
more with a sort of post-liberal
anti-capitalist type approach that this
is like productivity culture is really
just part of the superstructure that
supports the base of exploitative
capital extraction right like we need to
it's an economic argument you know so
there's just these different arguments
uh
celeste is more comes at it from more of
a cultural odell comes at it with a mix
of
humanist and economic and
artistic and that's i think that's why
that's a phenomenal book i think it's
very smart
very original and so we all there's just
these different takes that are all
coming at it and all all add something
but they're all getting at the same
underlying issue of this sort of sense
of crushing overwhelm and busyness
you know i was thinking if this
new yorker
gig cs professorial life doesn't work
out for you you could actually
work on some
sobering children's books along the
lines of
dr seuss and the first one could be
called the despair is there
let's get these kids sobered up quick
yeah i'm gonna get worse buddy get ready
yeah
so
looking at that through and this this
may not be the best segue but i'm gonna
give it a shot anyway we were talking
about the deep life and i'm going to
lead into this
through that
and
i'm looking at a post of yours from 2020
and it says i strive to divide my
focused attention among four categories
community family friends etc craft work
and quality leisure i love that term
quality leisure constitution health in
parentheses and last contemplation and
then in parentheses matters of the soul
so i'm going to ask you not the second
but i'm going to ask you about that
fourth one contemplation matters to the
soul and the way that we're going to
move into that
is through john newport
so who was john newport
my father's father my grandfather
a
baptist theologian and scholar and one
of the only
of his era baptist apologists
meaning
basically someone who he was southern
baptist who was very interested in
actually going out there and
encountering other world views
understanding other
approaches to things and then trying to
make a case
let me make a case for
the the baptist christian worldview let
me actually go out there and make my
case as opposed to saying the
non-apologist approach of batten down
the hatches
we have it right i don't want to hear
about what else is going on there my
grandfather was someone who he hung out
with carl jung he would walk with
heschel in central park when heschel was
still at the the seminary there he would
study or he was at harvard for a year
hanging out with niebuhr right i mean he
was out there
exposing himself to every
interesting idea and worldview and
approach that's out there he would want
to understand them deeply and then try
to understand why he
the advantages of his through comparison
and not to get too philosophical but it
was a sort of socratic
dialectical approach oh this question is
very much a philosophical question so
let's not
so but he would find it you you would
get more strength in what you which is a
big thing i took from him you know he
was a lifetime right around him he he
died basically on his way to my high
school graduation so i knew him
throughout my entire up to the beginning
of my adult life
the dialectical method of in
encountering and fully understanding a
different approach your understanding of
the world and your convictions will get
stronger that you don't want to try to
avoid or sidestep or discredit before
you have to see them
go hang out with heschel go hang out
with neighbor go hang out with tilik you
wrote a book on paul tillich go hang out
you know with yoon and really understand
and that don't be afraid of it who is
paul tillich just so i know i'll admit i
don't i don't know that name he was a
christian apologist he's like a
christian theologian you know sort of of
the same rough era c.s lewis
but was a little more academic than
lewis but so it's like
very smart apologia like really trying
to under explain like the christian
worldview let me pause for a second so
apologist i would imagine for some
people
has a
sort of a negative
connotation to it but it doesn't seem
like that's how you're using this word
would you mind just
explaining the use of of that term
there's a technical definition that i'm
using so so like the technical
definition of an apologist is just that
you're someone who is
out there making a case for the thing
that you believe in the effort of
explaining it to other people
it doesn't have to be evangelical in the
in the general sense of that term in
terms of you're trying to convince
people but at least you're trying to
encounter
other people and explain
why you're what you
the thing that you're trying to explain
is right so i mean a lot of like what
writing you do or i do is technically
would be
apologia like if i write a book you know
deep work i'm a productivity apologist
yeah like i'm a concentration apologist
that's a confusing term do you have any
idea how that became like the
etymological reasons it came out of
theology came out of theology i think it
might have i don't want to talk out of
school i might be wrong about that
you're right though it's not in common
parliament so i should
advocate maybe yeah but the main point
is in the southern baptist church at
that time you wouldn't see a lot of
apologia because you didn't want to go
out there and encounter other world
views like that like i would i just
don't even want to know about that
right and i think we see a lot of that
today i mean outside of the religious
context and so you know
we talk about this a lot on my podcast
but
don't be afraid of
ideas or worldviews or approaches or
philosophies that are that seem
different than what you believe in
you're not going to get tricked
into out of your convictions or
believing something that's false you
actually strengthen your understanding
of the world and therefore strengthen
your own convictions by encountering
other ideas that are well formed and
that's that's it's at the core of
the intellectual life for the last
however many centuries we want to say it
that's sort of a core operation and he
personified that
so if we look at the
the contemplation bucket and then
parentheses matters of the soul
so this is
one of your four categories of focused
attention
what does that mean to you
how do you focus on contemplation and
matters of the soul
the way i would generically tackle that
would be to say that humans have these
intimations
where
this seems
right or good
or awe inspiring this doesn't seem right
this doesn't seem good like certain
behaviors you see you know in a movie
the villain and it's just it hits this
thing inside like that's not that's not
right you're watching secession on hbo
and you're like all of my moral
intuitions are telling me that
these are bad people don't be like these
people right you know what i mean and we
get on the other side too that you you
encounter the inspiring and you the the
person who sacrifices or what have you
and it just
hits something inside and you feel it
right and and so you can call these
intimations
like john height would call these moral
intuitions there's there's different
terminologies for it
critical i think and this obviously by
eye i mean like all of philosophy but
you know
critically i think in all the theology
for that matter too is figuring out how
to actually structure a life around
these intimations a life that
pushes you more towards the things that
just instinctually hit you as this is
this is right and good and i just know
it and away from the things and the
behaviors and the approaches to life
that just hit you at a gut level as this
is not right this is not good it hits me
off this is what philosophy does this is
what religion does if we think about it
from a big picture perspective is
ideas evolved over time through
experience and argument that essentially
help you align your life with the things
that the moral intuitions that are
positive and away from the ones that are
negative it's why you shouldn't be quick
for example to dismiss a field of
philosophy or religion as like i can
just figure this out from scratch or
it's
talking about
mythologies that i can't empirically
validate in the world what you really
have there is a moral technology
something that's been evolved over time
to align your life with these intuitions
that you feel
and that's the contemplation bucket
is
you better be doing something along
those lines because just winging it is
not going to matter and so you know i
spend a lot of time trying to think
about that bucket
some details of how i tackle that maybe
is personal some are not
i engage a lot in philosophy
there's religious engagements in my life
i'm not
formally practicing and associated with
a particular religion
but that's also something that might not
i don't think that's necessarily a
permanent state i think there is a lot
of
intuition and brilliant human
moral engineering uh in religions well
if you're open to it i'd love to to talk
a bit more about this because i've i've
heard for instance
conversations between
sam harris who's a friend and
jordan peterson and i'm going to i'm
sure miss represent both sides so sorry
guys i'm just going to kind of
paraphrase but
you know in general jordan refers to
mythology
and
the bible as
sort of
moral frameworks
that have been time tested
which is not to say i don't think he
would say that we should base all of our
lives on cain and abel or something like
that
but the fact of the matter is that as
humans we've had a whole lot of trial
and error over a very very long period
of time certain stories have have struck
a chord and stuck
and maybe there's value in those stories
and then
again sorry sam i'm sure i'm
misrepresenting but if sam is perhaps
arguing that you should start from first
principles you do not
need theology or religion but can build
a moral code and framework for yourself
i think jordan's response to that would
be you're expecting too much of people
like people are just gonna have too much
trouble doing that they want something
out of the box that is good enough to be
helpful
so what i'd love to ask you is and i
spend a good amount of time thinking
about these things
for myself just for myself uh not for
anything else but my life and
i would love to know what this does for
you maybe we could start there like what
what is the
what is the need that it satisfies or
the
unease that it quells to have
contemplation slash matters of the soul
as one of the four main categories maybe
we could start there
and i'd just uh love to hear you expand
in in any way you feel comfortable in
that particular division
my
my instinct is that jordan is probably
more on the right path
and and i'll tell you a book that really
was
striking to me that i i think gets right
at this there's this great book
called all things shiny
and it was written by a philosopher from
harvard and a philosopher from berkeley
dreyfus and i forgot the other name
but they they talk about this issue
right so this was this was the central
issue that this was what mitchell was
worried about like we are now going to
have to create morality from scratch and
that's not going to go well right and
obviously jordan is very keyed into this
because
his early
interest was in the rise of totalitarian
regimes that occurred in the 20th
century in that context and spoiler
alert things did not go well
but there's this lament in that book
about it's looking at these prior
periods in human history where they use
the word the sacred but they talked
about life was just infused with the
sacred and in ancient greece the
classical greece they really did feel
like the gods the olympian gods would
inhabit you you know like ares would
inhabit you and that was to feel like
these feelings you would have was
literally god's inhabiting you and in
the medieval christians everything had a
place and a sacredness to it even
objects in the world and then that all
went away and they opened the book with
david foster wallace and basically
use him as personifying
i can just figure this all out from
scratch from first principles and and
they use them as a it's a really
poignant but tragic story because of
course it's a story that ends up with
foster wallace's suicide
and they they use that to set up the
the difficulty
of trying to build everything up from
scratch
and especially when i guess that's what
jordan likes to point out is
we have these
these intuitions that are really deep
and incredibly powerful
and uh you know jordan was very inspired
by jung so he's really drawing from carl
jung's you know j-u-n-g
his archetypes his idea that there's
these the collective unconscious that
has these archetypes that all humans
have they have a deep history
pre-culture and that like our myths the
reason why certain myths resonate is
they're pressing these buttons and
those those buttons what he would call
archetypes jung i think of his
intuitions and that
we have these technologies for sort of
and i'm using technology not digital or
electronic but
philosophical and theological
technologies like it really
it aligns your life to these things
we're we're meant to be aligned to them
just like our sense of thirst means we
really need to drink water you know we
shouldn't just ignore that and say is
there another way for me to achieve like
the proper isotonic balance in my
bloodstream like actually the instinct
just plans to drink water
some
all of those things have been very
effective to me
you know with an a effective in the
sense of like
affecting me
and so i think there's something to that
is that
i mean a life that alliance with these
intuitions can be very resilient and
rich and then we just have personal
experience and you know some people get
this through philosophy
and some people get this through
religion and but they're drawing from
the same internal hooks and so i get
very nervous
when i think about the challenge the the
nachian
that's the word challenge of
going back to first principle and we
tried i mean this was all a philosophy
tried to do this for a couple hundred
years like what kant was trying to do i
mean we all we tried this is very
difficult to this and i know sam
disagrees and he's smarter than me so
like you know let's listen to him maybe
more more than we listen to me
but
you know that's where i fall on that if
that makes sense
yeah this is a topic of kind of infinite
interest to me
and i'd love to
keep batting things around for a little
bit if you're open to it so i actually
have all things shining downstairs all
things shining subtitle reading the
western classics to find meaning in a
secular age by hubert dreyfus and sean
doris kelly
i was gifted this book and
you would think based on the title and
how much of a stoicism and philosophy
nerd i am
that i would have just taken to this
like a fished water i found it very
challenging to read
and
i think perhaps it was just all the
references
to
moby dick
and in the odyssey it could have been
that i'm not sure but i found it
i found it very
dense in a way that made it hard for me
to at least process at the time that i
was i was gifted it
and
i'm just going to mention a few things
kind of in no particular order
and the fact of the matter is i don't
know
jordan
peterson well we've spoken before and
i've had him on the podcast but i don't
know him well
i would say i know samwell and have
spent a lot of time around sam i use his
waking up app i've read many of his
books and we've just spent a lot of time
in person sam by and large
is a very seems to me to be a very happy
app piece guy
right so that's interesting that
now is that sam out of the box how much
of that is nature versus nurture and
training versus default i can't say i
have no idea but um but he has managed
it seems to thread the needle
and
sort of create meaning and frameworks
for himself they really seem to work
well
and
certainly there are counter examples and
when i see a book like all things
shining do you know the backgrounds of
the two co-authors in other words were
they backing into
the book from the perspective of people
with
religious upbringings or do you not know
the background
i know their background i i think sean
was
kelly was doran's his
advisee or some such but
yeah i i don't know i think they're
because they end up in a non-religious
place by the way right so if you get to
the end of that book where they end up
basically saying
craftsmanship craft is the the solution
to re-injecting
sacredness in a secular world so they do
not end up with saying what we need is
religion or uh stoicism or particular
philosophy end up saying
craft is
partially our savior because when you're
trying to build do something at a high
level
you have a rigid framework of value that
if you're a wheel right some wood is
better than others regardless of what
other system you've created it's just an
external reality this wood is better
than that wood and it's a way to
actually get some firmament so they end
up saying you should focus on basically
your work or you know craft and taste
and quality it's actually maybe not that
far from where sam is so
i think it's a really interesting point
yeah maybe they ended up converging i
mean it's also very
not to paint with too broad of brush but
having
lived in japan and having gone to school
there and speaking and reading and
writing japanese i feel like i have some
to say that it's all it's also a very
japanese
it's or a very prevalent sort of
japanese sentiment and predisposition is
to
focus on the sort of meticulous
attention to detail within craft as a
means of creating the sacred whether you
look at the tea ceremony you look at
kyudo which is the japanese archery
there are many many different sort of
instantiations if that's the right word
of this
throughout the culture
which is by and large not always but by
and large
can be
experienced through a secular or
religious
lens in japan
japan's a fascinating example i can't
remember
the exact expression it's in japanese
i'm doing a terrible job of
mangling a translation here but
it's it's something along the lines of
we are
buddhists when we're born
christian when we get married and shinto
when we die i might actually have it in
the exact opposite but you know shinto
when we're born
christian when we're married and uh
buddhist when we die
but
what comes to mind for me when looking
at all of these
different approaches to
trying to
check the box of contemplation or
matters of the soul
is that and i'd love to hear what you
think of this
because there's no right and wrong how
would i prove this is that humans
really do not like the discomfort of
uncertainty in the paradox of choice
presented by
a life that is largely messy and outside
of our control and therefore
we want frameworks and rules
so that we kind of
constrain the universe of things that we
need to think about does that make sense
yeah as such something like the ten
commandments very helpful
right
and
having strict rules
for what you can say eat or not eat
are very helpful in some ways it just
removes certain territories of life that
you need to think about or at least
you have some reassurance that you don't
need to worry about
and
at the same time there's part of me that
thinks well you know religion is
fantastic for that and i did not grow up
religious i've been exposed to a lot of
religion and honestly
very often i i have extreme
envy of people with strong religious
conviction for precisely that reason
right i i just feel like i'm trying to
david foster wallace my way through life
and it's
really hard and
can be very at least for me
destabilizing just have this universe of
infinite options and potential
decision making
at the same time i think well
if we are
accepting religion because it is this
pervasive
not to make it bad almost universal
instinct of humankind which which it
seems to be like myth-making
not saying that's what religion is but
meaning making through stories and and
religion in some fashion
really seems to be an evolved
instinct of some type
but we could also say
without certain constraints there are
other impulses humans have
that we constrain
and i know i'm going on and on a bit
here
but it's um
these are some of the questions that you
know remain with me as i continue to
explore
in my case i think i've sort of
passed the point of no return with
respect to
a specific
denomination of religion i just i don't
expect that i will be able to for a
million reasons
get there so looking at the alternatives
these are some of the questions that i
end up
pondering i mean if you are talking to
someone let's say you're talking to
students who are in a similar position
maybe they had a really terrible
experience
being brought up in a religious
household or perhaps just for for any
number of reasons they're just not going
to end up at
religion are there other ways you would
suggest they explore because you said
philosophy but philosophy is so broad
right i mean you could just
go and walk into a philosophy department
at any university and man you've got you
do have a paradox of choice situation on
your hands if you're if you're an
undergrad and going to like epistemology
101 and kind of getting walked through
it that's fine
but if you're
trying to use philosophy to help figure
out your life and starting from scratch
do you have any secular recommendations
for folks any other recommendations or
thoughts yeah it's a great question and
i just want to throw one
one idea into the mix i mean this is
it's a common idea in some theological
circles but i think the author
karen armstrong
makes this argument very well in her
book the case for god she is actually
not religious affiliated she used to be
a nun and had a bad experience and left
the catholic church but she has this
magisterial book called the case for god
and long story short
she said we don't understand religion
today and by today she means after the
enlightenment
because we think about it as the
ascent to empirically validated truths
you know like i have to to be religious
means that i
here's this thing that you this happened
this person did this and i agree that
this happened this is true right you
know but i don't
quote-unquote believe that or what have
you and her argument is like through all
the history of religion it's actually a
commitment to action and is after you do
the action that the insight comes
that you start by doing the things
and then later that gains you
revelation that's where you actually
start to gain
you know insight and understanding you
don't start with okay i think this is
right like some empirically validated
thing like i think gravity is right and
so now i i can be all on board with it
and that was a really interesting take
i thought that was really interesting
we're not as used to it now because
we're used to the
world after descartes where it's all
about we're in our head doing
rationality and so like okay religion
like any philosophy we have to work our
way up to it and believe it and then we
can go off and do it and you know some
religions are
better about that than others i think
like the jewish tradition doesn't care
so much about what's going on in your
head do these things right and then
you'll have revelation which is like
through experience acting as if now you
don't overthink this this god in yahweh
and you've got to do this and don't eat
that and do that and you need to your
family is very important blah blah blah
you do this stuff and over time you
deepen your understanding of the what
she calls the ineffable things you can't
even put into words anyways
in her mind all of religion is trying to
basically get intimations of the
ineffable through action and we think
about it too much like here's a
alternative to my history book and do i
think this is right or not
which is interesting and i think it's
like a really it's one of these
mind-blowing i don't know what to do
with it i just think it's a really
interesting point and i've been just
trying to get people to read her because
i think that's a really cool book and is
is underappreciated so philosophy can do
you're right a lot of philosophy is
complicated i think this is why you know
our mutual friend
ryan holliday is really doing well right
now is because he's making stoicism
accessible
and i know he's very influenced by you
and in that work and you've done a lot
to make stoicism accessible
and
that has done a lot of good for people i
think also
committing to communities of character
seems to help people so okay like when
people are very committed to their role
in the military it's a it's a community
of character community in which there's
certain characters underlined and
emphasized and there's sort of a
structure there people get this through
other types of causes or volunteerism
where you're committed to a community
that actually tries to
live true to certain characteristics
elements of character they think are
important i think that can get you there
too
but i'm really taken by that armstrong
idea of act first insight second yeah
get out there and start doing it it's a
quote i don't have the attribution but i
think about it often which is easier to
act your way into a new way of thinking
than to think your way into a new way of
acting and what you say also brings up
for me
memories from
several trips to the middle east so i've
i've spent a decent amount of time in
the middle east and
what i've heard more than once from
both jews and muslims is you would you
would hope for us to find more common
ground because
in our religions and i say this as a
non-jew and a non-muslim so forgive me
if anyone out there if i get this wrong
but
we believe in action like what you do
matters what you believe is really
secondary like what you do matters and
that's
at least you know they would contrast
that with some other religions where
like what you believe matters first like
you can do all the worst things in the
world and believe
certain things and then you are saved
and it's those are fundamentally very
very different right and i don't i don't
have a particular
perspective to add there
but
it is a contrast right and
these are things that i will obviously
continue to to think on
because i
find
precisely for
maybe some of the reasons that you
already mentioned the persistence of
the endurance and durability of religion
to
be fascinating even if i disagree with
any of the tenets
of
say all religions the fact that it is so
persistent is very very interesting
right like are we
evolutionarily
programmed to
create have adhere to religion in the
same way that birds are programmed to
build bird nests right
i don't know maybe it's it seems
entirely possible i'm going to take a
super hard left turn on topic shift if
that's okay with you
because i promised it
so segwaying from
religion and finding meaning and
contemplation let's talk about digital
minimalism for a second so i would love
to hear you expand
on your suggestion of people doing a
30-day digital minimalism experiment
where one removes optional technologies
yes i appreciate the congruence we're
making here between
the islamic and jewish understanding of
the meaning of the world in life and
also my 30-day declutter these are all
basically the same
we're all in kind of the same
ontological category here yeah yeah
tomato to motto you know we're all going
the same direction yeah exactly yeah but
we got you know
we have the the profits and also you
know 30-day declutter all that's kind of
the same now in fairness if you have
let's just say stocks on your iphone and
twitter push notifications
and
everything else
just giving you a
a psycho-emotional death by a thousand
paper cuts how do you expect to find
ultimate meaning in life it's gonna be
tough it's gonna make it an uphill
battle right so that's my attempt at
tying it together
all right let's talk about this this
suggestion this experiment
potential and what that what that might
look like for people and feel free to
obviously add anything that you would
like but this is something that
i think a lot of my listeners would be
very very interested in considering
doing
the 30-day
declutter is at the
the core of my philosophy of digital
minimalism so this was
my take on
what do we do about the fact that
starting around 2016
people became very uneasy about their
phones in a way that they weren't in
2014 there was this flip that switched
where at some point we realized
i'm looking at this thing too much like
this is a problem we got we got uneasy
and i could tell very precisely where
that happened just based on reactions to
my own work when it switched from you're
crazy you're crazy you're crazy you're
crazy you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right it happened in like a
very
quick period where my social media
skepticism in particular
really switched and so
my approach to it was
you can't start with the habits and the
tactics right you can't start with like
let me get right to
setting filters and turning off
notifications and not having my phone in
my bedroom and putting my my phone into
grayscale and moving my icons onto the
back screen on my iphone
that doesn't work you're going to end up
back where you were
and so
digital minimalism by contrast was this
humanist philosophy where it says no you
got to figure out what you're all about
like what you really care about and what
you want to do
and then work backwards and say what
text supports that
and that's how you choose
what tech you use in your personal life
and what rules you put around it you
start with what's important to me and
then you put the tech to work that's
much more sustainable but how do you
figure out this question like how do you
get that insight into what do i really
want to do what's important to me when
you already have all that distraction
that's where the declutter came in and
so i said take 30 days where you don't
use social media you don't stream
online videos the only podcast you
listen to is tim and minds and everyone
else you stop listening to no video
games no online news that's very
influenced by you and your low
information diet for example and you
experiment and you reflect and you think
about life and go for walks and join
things and ride your bike and hang out
with friends without you know sending
them messages on a glowing bitmap screen
and you figure out what you're all about
and then at the end of the 30 days
you say what do i want to do and so i
had that idea
i mentioned it to my newsletter because
i was working on this book but it was in
the early days
and i said does anyone want to try this
and my thought was this is a big ask so
maybe seven people would say yes and my
plan was that's great i will follow
these seven people
and see how it goes and write like
pretty long profiles of them it'll be
good for the book
sixteen hundred people came back and
said yeah i'm doing it wow so i get
through that idea that i was going to
follow everyone
1600 people did it
one of the people who was doing it was
the roommate of a new york times
reporter so then the new york times was
covering the declutter like it became a
whole thing and then they i got hundreds
and hundreds of reports back from people
about their experience and what worked
and what did it but the main takeaway
was
it is much more effective if you want to
tame the
technology in your personal life if you
want to tame that if you're working
backwards from first principles of this
is what i want to do with my life how
can tech help it's incredibly
sustainable if you instead say i'm
unhappy with all the tech i'm using now
so let me try to put in rules to use it
less that's incredibly non-sustainable
you're almost certainly going to go back
to where you were before
so if people want to
give this a shot what should they do
well i mean beyond the obvious of buying
the the book i ended up writing plus you
should start obviously yeah and a copy
for each of your friends because it's
easier for them to read it than you to
have to explain it once you've done that
it's actually straightforward
so literally what i say is just i call
them optional
personal technologies and i want to draw
a really clear line here this is really
about your personal life i've written
other books about email and slack and
technology in the working world that's a
whole other issue and it seems similar
but there's different issues underlying
it so therefore different solutions but
i'm talking about
the stuff you do outside of work that
largely speaking has you looking at your
phone
you take a break from them from 30 days
if it's a dual use technology like i i
mainly use this for personal reasons but
there's some reason i need to use it
then you put up fences right so if
you're like i don't want a text message
but my daughter uses text messaging to
tell me when she needs to be picked up
from practice you put up a fence and say
well i'll still do that but i'm not
going to participate in text change with
my friends for the 30 days so you can
you can set the rules how you want to
set the rules
and then the only key thing is you go
through 30 days
be very active so in that experiment the
people who treated this like a detox
and i hate the application of that term
the technology i think it's a complete
misappropriation of that term people who
try to just white knuckle it and say yes
i'm just not going to use these
technologies for 30 days and just by not
using them something positive will
happen they never made it 30 days
but the people who are like i will now
be very aggressive about
reflection and experimentation trying
new things going places going to the
library buying a bike joining a running
club you know reading books going on
long walks
they're the ones who really kept with it
and then at the end of the 30 days you
literally write out a code
here is the tech i use and the rules by
which i use it you know i'm going to use
instagram because i'm an artist but the
only way i'm going to use it is on my
computer the only people i'm going to
follow are these 10 artists that really
inspire me and i have a glass of wine
and look at their latest post on friday
evening and it's the only interaction i
have with that service right so you get
specific i'm using this for this reason
here's how i use it
and then you're you've reset you've
married condo'd your digital closet you
took everything out you only put back in
the stuff you cared about and uh and you
go for it
wine on friday for an instagram scroll
through 10 inspiring artists does sound
like it would spark joy
so thank you riconda
she's the tiniest woman
i've maybe ever met in my life she was
on the podcast 100 years ago i actually
interviewed her in japan and she's the
most
perfect
porcelain skin i've ever seen on any
human
really really
may in fact be an alien very sweet a
very organized alien though so
she's very organized alien be really
discouraging if this hyper advanced
alien civilization showed up and they're
really really disorganized just
couldn't figure things out you'd be like
oh no we thought we had so much clarity
to look forward to
and
it sounds like from your description
that the people who approach
this type of digital
minimalism experiment as one of
subtraction and that's their focus
they fail and those who view it as an
experiment with
new additions or substitutes to kind of
crowd out default
tech behaviors
are the ones who end up benefiting most
is that a fair
description
yeah we're good at humans to committing
the things that are positive like that's
very motivating for us
we're bad at trying to avoid things that
are negative right so it's very bad for
us to be like uh i think i use instagram
too much
i'm gonna try to use it less is like
that isn't very compatible with our
wiring but on the other hand like i i
have this vision of my life that it's
really positive and it makes me feel
good i'm really into it oh and by the
way that's a vision in which i don't use
instagram is way more effective
do you still use and this could be a
dead end and we can just cut it if so do
you still use a shutdown ritual
oh you close your computer you do
all right could you please describe for
folks
what the shutdown ritual is
at the end of your workday you you go
through and you close use the david
allen term
all the open loops
so okay let me make sure there's nothing
i missed there's not like an email i had
to answer that was very urgent that i
forgot about
you look at your weekly plan and your
calendar what's going on tomorrow i know
what i'm doing tomorrow okay my plan
makes sense you look at your task list i
didn't forget to do something today that
was very urgent all right i i'm good to
stop working and then you have to do
some sort of demonstrative
ritual at that point to indicate that
you did all those checks so
back in the early days on my blog the
the thing that me and my readers always
talked about doing was actually saying
the phrase
schedule shutdown complete
because it's absurd right like it's a
weird absurd thing but the the whole
idea was
then later on when your monkey brain
turns on is like work work work i'm sure
we're missing things ah right like we do
instead of having to go back and say i
have to now have a whole conversation
with my monkey brain about well let me
look at my calendar and i did this i did
that
you can short circuit all of that
and say i said the absurd phrase i would
not have in any
other time in my life have said that
phrase if i hadn't actually gone through
all the steps of making sure there was
nothing open so i don't need to get into
it i said the phrase i know i'm okay
and when people would do this it would
take about a week or two and it would
significantly reduce that evening or
morning work anxiety where your mind's
like uh i'm sure we're forgetting
something else let's go over the email
that we sent was that the wrong thing to
send and you can just say i said the
stupid thing
and i would never have said that stupid
thing it's like i had to shut it down it
look i created it because i needed it as
a grad student i created it and it took
on a life of its own there's a lot of
people out there looking left looking
right making sure they're alone and then
under their breath going schedule
shutdown complete
schedule
shutdown complete that is so fantastic
oh just great
well
cal
this has been a very fun conversation
thank you for taking the time i don't
want to end it prematurely i want to of
course ask is there anything else that
you would like to
share
i'm in no rush is there any type of
closing comments requests for the
audience anything you'd like to point
people to anything at all that you'd
like to
say or ask before we wind to a close
no this has been great i i love the
territory we covered
awesome i really appreciate you taking
the time it's nice to see you
and for everybody listening we will have
show notes links to everything all the
resources to all of
cal's books
including deep work digital minimalism
and his latest a world without email
we'll also link to a number of his new
yorker pieces to the deep questions
podcast and you can find him online not
on any
social media platforms but at cal
newport c-a-l-n-e-w-p-o-r-t
dot com
and until next time
be safe
experiment often
and
thanks for tuning in schedule shutdown
complete
you